[Música]
[Aplausos]
todo niño busca desde muy corta edad el
tener un ejemplo de lo que es ser un
hombre de verdad
a mis 6 años lo que yo quería lo que yo
más quería era ver a mi padre llegar a
casa abrazarlo y aprender de él estar
con él para seguir aprendiendo porque él
era mi primer ejemplo de lo que era ser
un hombre
pero lo que tuve fueron tardes enteras
esperando a que llegara que cuando lo
hacía era con un aroma intenso alcohol y
con unas ganas de enseñarme a ser
hombrecito
me jaloneaba me empujaba me intentaba
provocar para que me defendiera y me re
prendía cualquier muestra de dolor
cualquier muestra de llanto
para los 13 años yo ya lo odiaba en
secreto
él ya había engañado mi madre había
hecho otra familia se había ido de casa
pero tenía esta idea de que quería que
fuéramos amigos
me preguntaba seguido cómo estaba pero
el resentimiento que yo sentía con él ya
no me dejaba responderle nada
a esa edad en la secundaria lo menos que
yo quería era ser como él así que lo
primero que hice fue buscar otro ejemplo
de cómo ser un hombre
y al que elegí fue a fernando un amigo
de la secundaria
no es la mejor idea que un niño de 13
tenga como ejemplo más colonia de otro
niño de 13
fernando había estado en clases de box
así que sabía pelear era muy serio no
mostraba emociones
y tenía un pegue con las chicas
en cambio yo era el más risueño y el más
ocurrente de toda la escuela
pero eso cambió cuando ya intenté ser
como él
cuando intenté copiarlo
empecé a ser muy serio empecé a ser muy
callado
y siempre estaba pensando como verme más
rudo como ser más rudo
en mi casa mi madre estaba peleando
contra el reciente divorcio ya estaba
todo menos emocionalmente disponible
no había día en la secundaria en que yo
me acercara a ella queriendo le contar
mi día en que ella me interrumpiera
alzando me la voz
así que en la escuela yo estaba
intentando a mis 13 años ser una persona
que yo no era
y en casa no tenía yo nadie con quien
hablar nadie que me escuchara
por todas estas experiencias fui
aprendiendo que hay ciertas reglas que
como hombres tenemos que seguir
no podemos llorar ni podemos mostrar
ninguna pizca de dolor
porque tenemos que aguantarnos como
hombrecitos
tampoco podemos mostrar cariño o amor a
nuestros compañeros
porque vamos a ser rechazados por los
demás hombres
y el ser rechazados es lo que más nos da
miedo cuando somos niños incluso cuando
somos adultos la cultura en la que
vivimos ahora aún ve muy incómodo que
como niños entremos a clases de baile de
canto de pintura
porque estas son cosas más de niñas
también siempre queremos enseñarle a
nuestros niños qué es lo que deben
practicar como deporte con qué juguetes
deben jugar y qué trabajos son los que
deben de realizar cuando crezcan
dividimos a los sexos por ideas que
hemos ido replicando por la cultura que
nos rodea
incluso hay estudios que nos dicen que
hay
bebés que están vestidos de azul y no se
descarga tanto y apapacha tanto como a
un bebé que va vestido de rosa
hasta ese punto está esa división
nos hemos creado esta idea
de que el hombre es por naturaleza más
agresivo y menos empático
pero la verdad es que ninguno de
nosotros ni hombres ni mujeres nace
siendo ni racista ni clasista
ni sexista ni cualquier forma de
discriminación que termine mixta
todo lo aprendemos de las experiencias
que tenemos cuando somos niños de los
ejemplos que tenemos a nuestro alrededor
ningún hombre es naturalmente violento
ni menos empático que la mujer y no hay
ninguna mujer que sea inferior al hombre
jamás
tenemos que parar toda idea que nos haga
pensar de esta forma
a esta idea de masculinidad
en que el hombre tiene que ser duro sin
sentimientos pragmáticos sin emociones
la hemos bautizado como masculinidad
tóxica
pero a mí no me parece que ese sea el
mejor término ya que no te deja tener
esa idea de que se puede mejorar de que
puedes salir de ahí
un compañero miedo de reino unido
prendan toxqui propuso que cambiemos
este término de masculinidad tóxica a
restrictiva porque porque restringe
toda emoción todo sentimiento toda forma
de expresión a niños jóvenes y adultos
y esta es la razón por la que vemos a
tantos hombres peleando entre sí
denigrando y pisoteando otras personas
es la misma razón por la que 7 de cada
10 niños en méxico sufren de bullying
poniéndonos en el primer lugar a nivel
mundial
y en la misma razón por la que una de
cada tres mujeres ha sufrido de
violencia física o sexual en sus
relaciones más cercanas
al mismo tiempo que es la razón por la
que 8 de cada 10 personas que se
quitaron la vida en los últimos años
fueron hombres
porque al restringir esa conexión entre
la mente y el corazón del hombre
restringimos también la habilidad de
poder desarrollar compasión y empatía
que esas son las bases los pilares
principales para poder amar y ser amado
desarrollamos a hombres que sólo ven por
sí mismos que solo piensan en sí que ni
siquiera saben quién son que tienen un
problema muy fuerte de identidad y por
eso terminan yendo contra su propia
humanidad
les hemos enseñado a usar sus puños para
defenderse del mundo pero no les hemos
enseñado a usar su corazón
todo hombre en algún momento de su vida
se ha enfrentado con este tipo de
masculinidad pero no hemos tenido ni el
conocimiento ni la experiencia para
saber enfrentarla para saber hacer algo
al respecto
en mi caso personal no fue sino hasta
los 23 años que me di cuenta que tenía
que hacer un cambio extremo en mi vida
que tenía que cambiar y solo porque vi
el dolor que le había causado la herida
que le había causado a la persona que yo
más amaba en ese entonces
a esa edad
yo estaba ya en el fondo había tenido
novia tras novia había sido infiel
muchísimas veces ya había sido un
completo patán
con mi padre
me llamaba a las 3 de la mañana en todo
menos en sus cinco sentidos para decirme
que me quería
y no hubo ninguna de esas veces que ya
me llamaba a esa hora en que yo no le
colgaran
ni siquiera las veces en que él se echó
a llorar me detuve de colgarle
en ese tiempo yo tenía una novia
lo único que superaba cuanto yo la
admiraba a ella era el amor que yo
sentía por ella
y sin embargo aún con eso es la persona
a la que más lastima a la que más ser y
y todo porque yo quería validar me con
otros hombres e impresionar a otros
hombres
el querer mostrarme como esta idea de
hombre que ya me había hecho por mí por
mi entorno fue lo que me llevó a
engañarla
por supuesto que me corrió de su vida
totalmente
y eso me hizo entrar en una etapa de
depresión profunda que casi me cuesta mi
vida
yo no supe nada de ella sino hasta medio
año después una noche me llamó a las
tres de la mañana y me sorprendió mucho
me dejó paralizado que me invitara a
irme con ella esa noche
se escuchaba muy rara su voz por el
teléfono
cuando llego por mi en su coche
recuerdo muy bien que abrí la puerta
y me llegó el mismo aroma que despedía
mi padre cuando llegaba a casa
cuando llegamos a su departamento no
pasaron ni cinco segundos y se echó a
llorar yo de verdad no tenía ni idea que
estaba pasando
pero se desplomó cayó al suelo y siguió
llorando y siguió llorando y así hasta
que se quedó dormida
esa noche yo no pude dormir
me di cuenta por primera vez del dolor
que yo le había causado a alguien
alguien que yo quería esa herida se la
había hecho yo y fue la primera vez que
yo me pregunte
de verdad valió la pena romperle el
corazón a ella por querer validar me con
otros hombres y encajar en un grupo de
hombres que ni siquiera están dentro de
esta relación
esa noche me decidí a que no más nunca
más iba a estar replicando todo lo que
había dañado a mi familia todo lo que me
había dañado a mí yo lo estaba volviendo
a hacer y dañando otras personas y hasta
ese punto me di cuenta
pero no iba a ser un cambio que iba a
poder hacer de la noche a la mañana
había mucho que tenía que aprender y
mucho que tenía que desaprender
en ese entonces empecé a estudiar sobre
masculinidad es sobre educación de paz
incluso sobre el lenguaje del amor
y me di cuenta
de que lo que más nos falta desarrollar
a los hombres es empatía
claro que como les digo no
y va a poderlo desarrollar de un día
para otro y va a ser todo un proceso y
dentro de ese proceso
me di cuenta de algunos puntos que son
clave
para poder desarrollar esta empatía y el
primero de ellos fue el autoconocimiento
no podemos entender lo que pasa en la
vida de otros o lo que sienten los demás
si no se si no sabemos primero lo que
sentimos nosotros lo que hay dentro de
nosotros
tenemos que aprender a preguntarnos qué
es lo que siento qué palabra es la que
describe este sentimiento ya sea
hablándolo en voz alta escribiéndolo o
platicando con alguien de nuestra
confianza
el poder dar esas palabras a esos
sentimientos y poder tener claro esto
nos permite delimitar donde termino yo y
dónde empiezan las demás personas ese es
el inicio del desarrollo de la empatía
otro de estos puntos fue
la autoaceptación
hay una frase que dice una investigadora
muy reconocida en el tema de la
vulnerable vulnerabilidad que se llama
bréyner brown
qué dice la verdadera pertenencia
solo ocurre cuando nos atrevemos a
mostrarnos como somos nosotros
imperfectos ante el mundo
por lo tanto nuestro sentido de
pertenencia nunca puede ser mayor a
nuestro nivel de autoaceptación
entre tantos hombres que quieren encajar
en lugar de pertenecer lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es quitarnos esa
máscara ponerla a un lado y así y auto
aceptarnos darnos cuenta que no somos
perfectos que somos humanos y que como
humanos vamos a cometer errores
no tenemos que saberlo siempre todo y
estar siempre en lo correcto
cuando aprendemos a auto aceptarnos
es el primer paso para nosotros aprender
a amarnos mejor
y después poder amar a los demás
otro de estos puntos y yo creo que uno
de los más importantes es la compasión
para empezar a desarrollar la compasión
y entender la compasión hay que estar
conscientes de que hay una historia
detrás de cada uno hay heridas que todos
tenemos por sanar hay cicatrices que
marcan la piel de cada uno que han
añadido a la máscara que todo nos cede
todos nos hemos ido formando para
protegernos de ser lastimados por los
demás a lo largo de nuestra vida
cuando nos damos cuenta
de que todos tenemos ese pasado de que
todos tenemos heridas todos hemos pasado
por algo nos permite empezar a aceptar a
otros también y tener esta compasión por
los demás incluso por nosotros mismos
me di cuenta que cuando yo empecé a
aceptarme a mí ya tener compasión por mí
mismo otros hombres empezaron a
aceptarse también es como si les hubiera
dado sin darme cuenta permiso de hacerlo
también a ellos
y el último punto acción
no necesitamos ser alguien que nosotros
no somos
tenemos que quitarnos esa máscara y
atrevernos tomar esa acción de dar el
paso y abrirnos ser nosotros no tener
nada en frente
entre las demás personas y nosotros solo
para encajar hay que preguntarnos que de
las cosas que hago son para encajar en
otros grupos y cuáles son realmente yo
el darnos cuenta de esto va a poder
entonces ayudarnos a quitar la máscara
de otros también a que otros se sientan
libres de quitársela y para nosotros
tener la oportunidad de esas personas
que se atrevan también como nosotros
hacerlo sentir aceptados y amados
todas estas historias y toda esta
experiencia que llegue a tener con mi
padre con mi familia y con mis
relaciones solo nos dan esa claridad del
porqué de muchas de nuestras conductas
disfuncionales
pero no es ninguna justificación para
seguir replicando las tenemos toda la
responsabilidad y toda la capacidad de
cortar ese ciclo y crear una nueva
cultura una donde el sinónimo de ser un
hombre de verdad
con pasión aceptación empatía y amor
a mis 23 años yo decidí empezar de cero
y cambiarme totalmente rehacerme
y ahora mis 27
siento muchísimo amor
cuando abrazó mi padre y le digo que lo
amo
porque como dijo benjamín disraelí un
hombre nunca es tan hombre como cuando
siente profundamente actúa con valentía
y se expresa con franqueza y fervor
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]